Reuters are saying that the legal
opinion is this the legal risk remains
unchanged the United Kingdom would have
no internationally lawful means of
exiting the protocols arrangements saved
by agreement in case of differences let
me see if I can just enlarge or what
that's saying I think more is going to
come through on this but tomorrow if at
first blush that looks like the legal
opinion is unchanged that's a
significant blow for Downing Street yes
we've just got it through you literally
in the last few seconds so we will have
to have a closer look at it over the
next few minutes but certainly a huge
amount is riding on the Attorney
General's legal advice he told him he's
back in December that his opinion on the
Prime Minister's withdrawal deal is that
Britain could remain trapped in the back
stop in there indefinitely
therefore MP Tory brexit ears and the
DUP were very keen to see that the
Attorney General's legal advice because
they figure that they trust he's a
brexit ear he's got a legal reputation
to uphold they were looking to see that
he would say what the prime minister
said in Strasbourg last night which is
that she believes that guarantees the
assurances tomorrow I just want to drop
you because you can't see what I can see
and the legal advice is coming through
in dribs and drabs and this may be
slightly contradictory to the initial
suggestion that the legal advice is
unchanged this is all coming from at
this what I'm looking at is covering the
Reuters news agency there were further
saying that joint instrument is legally
binding so that may be encouraging for
Downing Street the Attorney General's
legal advice on the backstop says the
joint instrument has binding legal
effects as a document going on to say
there is no doubt in my view that the
kalafat that the clarifications provide
a substantive and binding reinforcement
of the legal rights available to the UK
and this is all just being shared as
they go through the legal opinion and
tomorrow what what should we make of
this at this stage
I think what brexit ears and the DEP
will be looking for from this legal
advice they know that what the Prime
Minister got last night falls short of a
time limit on the backstop or an exit
mechanism that only the UK can trigger
what is in those assurances that Teresa
may it was pushing last night is the
idea that the UK can say if they feel
the EU is keeping the UK in the backstop
indefinitely they can go to an
arbitration panel which will make the
final decision to end the backstop they
want to see that Geoffrey Cox thinks
that that is a way out of it that it
isn't just reducing the risk but it is
actually eliminating altogether the idea
that Britain could be trapped in the
backstop eternally I was just speaking
to the de Pease brexit spokesman Sammy
Wilson because the feeling is that if
the DUP think this is enough then brexit
ears will fall into line as well he was
saying first of all that what MPs are
voting for tonight the motion tonight
says that it only reduces the risks of
the backstop we said that is not a
ringing endorsement and he also said
that the idea put forward by jean-claude
Juncker yesterday that this is the last
chance saloon MPs get to vote on it
tonight and then that is it
he said that won't sway their opinion in
any way they feel that if there is going
to be an extension there is more time
for negotiating so that is not very
encouraging for Theresa May and the
numbers are really stacked against her
even if she did manage to get all of the
10 D ups and all of the wreck cities in
her party onside which at this stage
looks very daunting a task indeed she
will still need some labour votes to
take this over the line because of
course she doesn't have a majority and
we're expecting that the small number of
Tories who's supporting a second
referendum who are still in the party
will vote against it tonight plus a few
others so it really is a difficult task
the Attorney General is going to the
Commons to take questions on this this
afternoon about his legal advice and I
think that MPs will be grilling him on
just those aspects that you mentioned
what then happens is that the hardline
brexit ears in the European research
group will be meeting this afternoon
after they have got some of their MPs
who are lawyers to look over it with a
fine-tooth comb and decide whether they
can support it I think the feeling in
Parliament is that it will be very
difficult for
to pull off a victory tonight but if she
pulls off a much smaller defeat gets at
230 vote defeat down to say twenty
thirty forty than perhaps her deal is
unlife support but still in contention
for perhaps perhaps possibly a third go
we are expecting to resume to leave
imminently from number ten cabinet has
now just finished to go to the Commons
to take questions from MPs she will be
meeting Tory MPs and I'm sure they will
be asking her about this legal advice
and what really has changed sure they
will tomorrow this is a synopsis of the
legal advice and we're passing it pretty
much as it comes through we draw
attention to these two items seventeen
and nineteen seventeen saying and this
is Jeffrey Cox's legal judgment I now
consider that the legally binding
provisions of the joint instrument and
the content of the unilateral
declaration reduced the risk that the
United Kingdom could be indefinitely and
involuntarily detained within the
protocols provisions at least in so far
as that situation had been brought about
by the bad faith or want of best
endeavors of the EU
this is legalese as you'd expect point
nineteen perhaps a little contradictory
the legal risk remains unchanged however
there if through no such demonstrable
failure of either party but simply
because of intractable differences that
situation does arise the United Kingdom
would would have at least while a
fundamental circumstances remained the
same no internationally lawful means of
exiting the protocols arrangements save
by agreement tomorrow it may be in
looking through this document the DUP
and others can find and cherry-pick
items that they say may support their
position that there is a legal Avenue
out of the backstop but at first blush
it's not as promising as it might have
been for them just looking at that Colin
he uses the word reduces the risk that
is exactly the words that are on this
motion that MPs are voting on tonight
that is changed from December but really
Breck cities in the dup want to see the
risk of staying in the backstop
eliminated they believe that they have
given in on a time limit that you said
they
put an end date on the back stock they
have given in on the fact that the
withdrawal agreement agreed by the 27
countries is not being reopened they're
just bolting on a bit at the end
reducing the risk I think many of them
will see it as really not good enough
for them to vote for it not only full
short of what they wanted but it doesn't
really give them a guarantee that the
backstop which is of course the
arrangement with which the whole of the
United Kingdom stayed in the customs
union with the EU until some other way
is found to keep the border open I think
that falls short of what many had hoped
for and the lawyers at the moment
Tory brexit here and DUP lawyers who are
looking over it at the moment going
through it with a fine-tooth comb were
waiting to see if the Attorney General
will come out with something a bit
stronger than that
as Sammy Wilson the DPS brexit spokesman
was telling me just a few minutes ago
reducing the risk is not exactly a
ringing endorsement so it's going to be
a difficult day for the prime minister
trying to convince them that Jeffrey Cox
who is a figure is very respected people
know that he has a legal reputation to
uphold that that is good enough it was
already a daunting task to try and get
this deal through Parliament without a
majority and with virtually no labor
support I was just speaking to a source
in the Labour Party in the Whip's office
who was saying they're not expecting
huge numbers of labour and pleas to back
this so that is not I think the ringing
endorsement they will need to get this
deal over the line it would appear at
the moment